and finally new rule now that graduation
season has ended and we won't be
spoiling anyone's big day
let's talk about what higher education
in america really is
a racket that sells you a very expensive
ticket to the upper middle class
president biden's american family's plan
asks the taxpayers to pony up hundreds
of billions so that everyone can go to
college
and billions more for a subsidized child
care so our kids can go to school while
we go to school
the theory being that all this education
trickles down and eventually gets to
florida
now
now the right is calling biden's plan
social engineering which is
over the top but biden's plan is an
endorsement of a particular idea
that the more time humans spend in
classrooms staring at blackboards the
better
liberals see more school the way
republicans see tax cuts as the answer
to everything we imagine going to
college is the way to fight income
inequality
but actually it does the reverse if you
have a bachelor's degree
you make about 65 more than someone who
doesn't and with a master's degree it's
more like a hundred percent more
and the unemployment rate of college
grads is about half what it is for high
school grads
i know free college is a left wing thing
but is it really liberal for someone who
doesn't go to college and makes less
money to pay
for people who do go and make more
i'm asking
especially since colleges have turned
into giant luxury day care centers
with overpaid babysitters anxious to
indulge every student
whim the university of missouri has a
river grotto inspired by the playboy
mansion
[Applause]
texas tech has one of the largest water
parks in the country that includes a
25-person hot tub
tanning deck waterslide and a lazy river
a third of students now spend less than
five hours a week
studying and when they do it's for their
onerous magnum [ __ ]
[ __ ] course load of sports marketing
history through
twitter advanced
racist spotting intro to
microaggressions and you owe me an
apology 101.
why is china kicking our ass because in
2019 we issued more undergrad degrees in
visual and performing arts
than in computer and information science
or math
say what you want about lori laughlin at
least she understood that one good
scam deserves another
[Applause]
and in the immortal words of her
daughter olivia jade
i don't know how much school i'm going
to attend but i do want the experience
of like
game days and partying
yeah i'm not [ __ ] paying for that
in 1960 colleges awarded aids
to 15 of the students well now it's 45
and it's not because they got smarter
it's because of adderall
yeah okay but also
colleges are businesses selling a
consumer product
for hundreds of thousands of dollars and
they want to give the customers what
they want
a magical piece of paper called a
diploma
but that's only the beginning of the
scam a wannabe librarian
needs a master's degree just to get an
entry-level job filing books
you know i've heard this from so many
nurses and teachers and administrators
rolling their eyes when relating how
they needed to take some [ __ ] course
in order to advance in their field and
really they already learned what they
need by working the job
but in the
[Applause]
but in the grift that is our higher
education when you want to
move up hold on there not so fast
toll booth ahead you need to pay for
more education before we decide if you
can do what you do
[ __ ] this is what scientology does makes
you keep taking courses to move up to
the bridge of total freedom
in the middle ages the catholic church
famously sold
indulgences which were just tickets to
heaven that you could buy
well now another priesthood of academia
sells a different ticket to heaven and
because it's so necessary colleges can
charge whatever they want
since 1985 the average cost of college
has risen
500 percent what are the business
it doubles every nine years every year
it increases at four
times the rate of inflation and yet no
one knows how to change a tire
the answer isn't to make college-free
the answer is to make it more
unnecessary
which it is for most jobs
so that the two-thirds of americans who
either can't afford to or just don't
want to go
don't feel shut out because the system
we have
sets up this winter loser dynamic and
breeds resentment
that working hard has less value than
sitting around in this thing
and that that in turn
feeds into our widening political
division
or as one recent politician put it
i love the poorly educated
you